Nikki where are you from originally
where did you grow up um I was actually
born in the Balboa Naval Hospital my dad
was in the Navy but that was short-lived
and then I moved to Long Beach and I've
been in pretty much everywhere that you
could think of my mom and my dad split
when I was very young because my dad
used to do drugs and beat on my mom and
so um they separated and my mom was a
single mom
they had brothers and I'm the only girl
and the oldest so then my mom became an
addict and I became mom slash sister
slash hunt slash babysitter for all my
mom's home girls and their children you
know
so I'm nine years old and a child myself
and knew how to make mixed drinks and
pick up my drunk mom off the floor and
take care of my brothers and we were
really poor you know like really poor
people say we were poor when we grew up
but and then I hear what they say you
know and how they live their life and no
poor we were poor like we we would wet
wet magazine you know what I mean and
wipe our but sometimes you know like
electricity would be off
I remember being nine years old and
walking from door to door you know
asking different neighbors for different
things so I could feed being my brothers
in that kind of pour and then I learned
how to steal you know and that like
saved my family you know my mom even
knew that I was stealing but she was so
far in her addiction that she didn't
even care and she she somehow made it
right to herself
you know well God knows God knows our
heart
I remember she used to say that and she
saw me she saw me for a dope side when I
was 12 - her boyfriend's brother and
that's when that's when pretty much my
life had so good took a turn you know
because my innocence was taken from me
at that time sorry and and so then after
that point I just I'm 12 years old and
really didn't know too much about life
you know I knew that as far as I was
concerned life was rough but because
that's all that I had been through I
didn't even really realize that what I
was going through was abnormal you know
until I started hanging out with people
who had normal lives but then because I
was so used to having chaos around me
that that would only be short-lived
you know I could only hang out with my
normal friends for so long and I had to
I had to hang out with gang members and
people who were older than me and
because that's just it was normal to me
you know the white since white picket
fences that was never anything that I
ever thought that I would be able to
attend you know but um yeah that's how I
grew up and then when I got a little bit
older like so so because I was so angry
right I got kicked out of several
schools
became a gang member was very
promiscuous because that was normal you
know because I didn't have a dad you
know my mom was promiscuous my mom was
an addict so seeing all those things for
so long you know it just kind of rubs
off on me
right and I got kicked at like eight
schools and I kicked out of the Orange
County District because I had gotten
into Orange County from Long Beach and
eventually I had to become homeschooled
and of course that didn't work well
because I already didn't have any
guidance so I finally graduated in high
school in County Jail when I was 25 but
never was really interested in anything
that was successful ever you know I
always had an interest and it always
looked good to me but I think somehow
there was something on the inside of me
that felt that maybe I didn't deserve
success you know so I've always
self-sabotage always my whole entire
life ain't booting now
I have to take a shower like I'm sorry
alcoholism is very ugly but it's real so
yeah but I don't like to mix it because
for somehow for some reason it feels
like it's less potent that way I need to
feel the burn I guess what I do remember
is because I've always been smart you
know I think maybe it's because I had to
be an adult at an early age and you know
I know during junior high and high
school teachers would try to send me to
leadership classes and they would tell
my mom who would always be high as a
[ __ ] kite when she would go to my
parent teacher conferences if she would
even show up you know she's so brilliant
you know she's very sharp she's smart
she just doesn't apply herself you know
is there anything that's going on at
home you know well yeah I mean she
doesn't have electricity and sometimes
she goes to sleep without eating and you
know I smoke crack and [ __ ] five
different men during the week you know
no that was never said
I had this um had this uh somehow my mom
gave me the reputation that she gave me
you know because she couldn't dare say
that it was her you know so she made me
the bad kid and I became the bad kid I
was always chubby you know so that was
rough for me
so instead of dealing with the fat jokes
or whatever the case may be I started
bullying others you know and I would
make fun of myself first school there's
one have a chance to do it I would act
like it didn't matter to me but because
I was so used to being the fat ho or
whatever from my mother you know the one
person that the one person everybody
your whole excited lady you would see
hey you can trust in love you know
betrays you like that and does the
things that they do the way that you
look at other people it just completely
says a different you don't trust anybody
and you have your guards up like it's
I can't even believe it I'm sure these
but um so
I became that kid in and out of juvenile
hall would always find I was very
violent
very violent because that's the way that
because I was beaten and raped and
molested and you know and I was so angry
I was so angry I hated my mother you
know I still hate my mom and that's sad
but I loved her at the same time and
nobody could ever say anything about my
mom because I would beat their ass but
um yeah that's like the gist of my I
mean and I've always I've always I
I've always been talented and you know I
sing I've always had a gift like I could
sing my ass off my mom stopped me from
doing a lot of things either because she
didn't want to pay for it or when I was
like 14 years old she decided to be a
born-again Christian right and then she
decided to Oh will you spare the rod you
spoil the child and then she thought
that she could beat me and my brother's
right and it was okay because that's
what the Bible says the [ __ ] we've
already been grown now we've raised
ourselves you know you want to try to
hit us now we've already been through
too much who the [ __ ] do you think you
are you know but I do remember as a
child I felt the power of God you know
and it didn't change the way that I felt
about the Lord
and I realized at that point in time
that you know what I do have a gift and
I do love God you know so I've been
through almost every aspect of life you
could think of and so even though my mom
was [ __ ] the usher who was who was
married you know and wondered why people
looked at her crazy and [ __ ] and they
used to do myth on the weekends when
nobody was looking
but God was you know and so I I like
prided myself in being different you
know I didn't want to have sex before
marriage I didn't want to you know I
wanted to do it the right way you know I
started doing good in school and was
actually on the honor roll for a little
while you know but then after after I
became home like I lost all hope right
after my grandma died my grandma died
and my grandma was the only person that
was the rock and my family my mom came
from a family of 10
you know she had ten brothers and
sisters her her brothers and sisters
they were all abusive to each other you
know and that's because my grandpa was a
raging [ __ ] alcoholic go figure
he actually died a cirrhosis of the
liver not too long ago and he used to
beat my grandmother who was the most
awesome lady you know it's some people
who are changed by their atmosphere and
in what they go through and some people
are not my grandma was never changed you
know it didn't matter didn't matter how
much [ __ ] she went through she was never
changed but everybody else was you know
after my grandma died and I no longer
had because my mom my grandma would put
my mom in check you know and say Theresa
no no no no no no you need to you need
to let her aspire and being a singer and
she's gonna be somebody and you can't
treat her that way and I would never I
would never tell my grandma exactly what
she did because even though my my mom
did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I didn't want my grandma to be mad at my
mom because I didn't want my mom didn't
mad at me because I always strived for
her approval still you know um and
that's that's basically where the hurt
starts you know the hurt started there
and it's in there
when did you when you left your mom's
house where did you go and I I had been
in and out of my mom's house
since I was 14 years old you know so
it's 14 you right away yeah
did you finish high school when I got my
GED in jail at 25 never finished never
finished I was too busy drinking and
gangbanging and trying to be accepted
because the neighborhood that I grew up
in was predominantly black and Hispanic
and I'm Egyptian in French you know like
I look like a white girl you know and so
I had to be harder then and little do
they know that I was angrier did a lot
of them so it didn't really take much
for me and then I was accepted and I
actually had a family it sounds stupid
but they were my family
and as far as I was concerned we would
die for each other that's not the [ __ ]
truth getting members most of the time
they're only loyal to each other to a
fault you know and to a certain extent
and once once once what they need from
you or what they want from you is over
their loyalty becomes less and less you
know don't get me wrong there are some
some people that keep it family you know
and and when you go to jail they're
there for you and you know but at the
end of the day you're the one that does
that time you're the one that's in that
cell all by herself because you have
your violent offender you know you're
the one who doesn't have anybody writing
you you're the one that doesn't have
anybody accepting your collect calls you
know so you just alone and then you're
around all these different criminals and
it makes you even more angry and a
better criminal because what happens
when you get a whole bunch of people who
have made mistakes you trade shows
mistakes and you become a better
criminal you know and that's what
happens and it's crazy but it's just a
vicious cycle I don't even I don't
believe in the jail system I don't
believe in the judicial system because
they're not for us they're running up
and what happens to an animal when you
cage somebody they either fight or they
flight and if there's nowhere to [ __ ]
run you have no other choice but to
fight and then that makes you order what
kind of stuff are you doing when you
were out on your own
when I was wet when you had left your
mom's house and you were on your own
what were we doing for money what did
you do with your time
Oh God um selling drugs doing drugs
[Music]
seven selling [ __ ] you know stealing
because I really because I was a gang
member and I had pride that the selling
[ __ ] part came way later in life you
know cuz I thought that hoes were just
disgusting at the time I had no idea
that that's a whole different aspect of
life and but anyway um but for the most
part because I was one of the youngest
you know you can you can go from pillar
to post
you know cuz you're young and you're
hurting and your mom is so [ __ ] up
that people actually care then when
you're young and it was a long time ago
I'm 40 years old
you know people who actually had a lot
more care for people then because
everything wasn't done on video and
online you actually had to have a
conversation with people and
[Music]
I mean I remember being younger and and
especially especially Kirby I have had
friends I have I've had friends who were
gang members or whatever the case may be
and had really good lives like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and you don't even
belong here like this is this is not for
you this is her people this is for
people who have no family and who are
who are hurting and who are rough like
there's a lot of that out here too a lot
of that out here and I say that to those
people too like [ __ ] are you doing you
hear you have a family yeah the [ __ ]
career you have so many things that you
so many other things that you could be
doing like I wish I could see my kids
you know but my rice got chicken and I'm
gonna see my kids in three years and my
baby is almost four you know what
happens till prison I'm a woman a mother
when their kids are ticket you take away
that reason I wake up every day god I'm
I'm jumping from high school to their
how I ended up out here but um three
years ago almost lived in Las Vegas
because I actually did I actually did
make something of myself you know for a
little while off and on I've had success
and then I [ __ ] it up and then I've
had success and then I [ __ ] it up you
know through I'll call ISM and
self-sabotage like I say um
I had a beautiful home in Las Vegas a
career I was modeling on the side
singing his videos you know I had all my
kids with me to cars like life was good
for me
my baby's dead Jamie Las Vegas and
picked a fight with me
you know and violence is you put me in a
corner I'm gonna fight it doesn't matter
whether I lose or when I'm you're gonna
get hit [ __ ] with me you know it's
just five brothers rough life this [ __ ]
just happens you know but um so I hit
him right and even though the kids were
not awake they were not even in the same
room there across the house asleep a
neighbor called because of his
disturbance right and Nevada does not
play like their laws are super strict
and because I already had a strike and a
violent crime they wanted a man like his
back and my mom decided hey I'll take
them and go take care of everything that
you need to take care of and I'll give
him back to you Nikki you know [ __ ] when
my kids first a teen because all I knew
right and everything [ __ ] up in my
life the one good thing that I did have
where my kids and I prided myself and
being a good mom man I tried my damage
dude even best mom that I could you know
that was a good mom and I didn't sleep
for nine days mark because every time I
cuz my baby was just a baby when he was
first dating I have three but my
youngest was just a baby
he was only one he had just her Mallick
he slept with me every day and so every
time I tried to close my eyes
I couldn't sleep because I didn't feel
complete one you know and then like
oppression just took over depression I
will close my eyes out here my baby cry
it was like I was almost being tormented
I mean I don't know if you believe in
spirits or whatever but it really felt
like I was being tormented by evil
spirits you know and nine days later I
guess from another disturbance my
[ __ ] neighbors were nosy as hell
oh um Las Vegas PD came into my house
and they had to break in because I at
this point on comatose you know but I
wasn't sleeping and when they walked in
um I was sitting at the table with a
gallon of Carlo Rossi in front of me and
before dinner plates at the table
because I was taking care of kids that
weren't there
I guess my body Edwin is um autopilot
you know and losing them was traumatic
to me so and then I was in the Las Vegas
um mental institution for two and a half
weeks and then they finally decided to
let me out and I went back to my
apartment
and I packed up everything that I could
in my little car and I went back to the
abuser and they abused you know baby's
dad and he was messed out you know swore
that he would help me get the kids back
he didn't want to help me
and so my addiction and his addiction
just became stronger and stronger you
know and then we became more and more
abusive to each other to a point where
we both went to jail for domestic
violence again lost everything so I get
out of jail my mom had changed her phone
number I didn't know where my kids were
so I felt like okay well [ __ ] it
I really have nothing and nobody so what
do you what do I do now so I really I
really went on destructive mode to the
point where I like wanted to die and
wanted to kill myself and tried many
times and for some reason there's
something that something or someone that
always stops me you know
I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't wish
some of the things that I've been
through and seen on anybody you know so
I got an I got into prostitution because
you know being on the street at this
point is dangerous you know and this is
when I first became homeless and I had a
I had a pimp you know and he he was the
one who was like hey well you like to
[ __ ] anyway so you might as well make
money doing it and so I started selling
myself and I made good money doing it
but I didn't get to keep it yeah bit of
course and you know there's all these
promises that are given to you yeah
we'll do this and we'll help you get
your kids back and so of course you know
I give my all and I got a a forever have
nothing to show for it
nothing but I did I did have a contusion
you know broken ribs no shoes and a
busted lip by the time I finally got out
of that situation almost a year later
and I got out of that through cast which
is a coalition against
sexual trafficking you know and they
brought me out here because where I was
being trafficked was in Orange County so
they brought me out here their their
main office is actually out here and
they put me in a hotel downtown next
thing you know I met a cute guy who told
me that he had a hotel and he'd be able
to help me and I'm so beautiful and dead
and untalented and I ended up on [ __ ]
hagatha and I've been out here since I
missed almost three years now it's
almost like Skid Row is a Twilight Zone
you know and because most of the people
here are so helpless and hopeless and
hurting so badly and it's so dog-eat-dog
out here and hurting people hurt people
you know I've been raped three times I
was kidnapped for three days
[ __ ] and it seems like every time I get
ahead even just a little bit I get
knocked back like in steps you know and
the men out then a lot of the men out
here are just [ __ ] they're predators
and they'll use anything love kids
shelter anything to get what it is that
they want from you and then once they
get what they want they just throw you
away like a piece of trash and then if
you decide not to you end up like me
angry bitter in the cold sick last year
it was so cold during the wintertime I
lost I had got pneumonia I lost hearing
in my right ear you know so it's like
[ __ ] you're damned if you do damned if
you don't
and then you get paperwork ready so you
could try to get an SRO and some of
these stairs your foot in person and
you're starting all over again and it's
hard to do anyway because guess what you
stay up all night so you don't have to
be subjected to anybody else's [ __ ]
right so you're tired as [ __ ] by the
time by the time the day comes right so
you do drugs to stay awake and because
you do drugs stay awake and you've been
awake all night you don't want to go and
take care of any business that's the
last thing that's on your mind and so
it's just another vicious cycle all over
again
it's like God so I wish I wish that God
would just really just put his hand down
and just do something about this that's
full of pain there's a lot of there's
people from all different types of life
out here people who are very successful
people who have had careers and lives
and down to the dirtiest you know like
it's people who are very talented I've
seen so many talented people on your
work it's a damn shame
you know would you just put his hand
down and just help help they're hurting
people out here you know and hurting
people hurt people it's a mate it's a
known fact
psychologically like mentally
emotionally you like if you've been
through some [ __ ] and you're hurting
you're either gonna have your guards up
so much to the point where you don't
care or you're gonna hurt others period
I mean I wish at least somebody would be
on some Robin Hood [ __ ] where they could
steal from the rich and give to the poor
but all these poor people are stealing
from each other and hurting each other
and selling drugs to each other
[ __ ]
it's like another world out here I know
you've seen it
how can all of society just go on around
us and nobody's seen what's going on
does that make sense it's always is if
it's some kind of conspiracy it's just
too painful to look at too painful to
process how for a lot of you how dare
this you no shame - shame on you - just
turn your face and go on with your
[ __ ] life well people are dying out
here three people just this year have
died from [ __ ] hypothermia because
it's cold out here
there are parasites and bugs and disease
and everybody's having sex with each
other and there's AIDS and like it's it
we're all gonna die right the fentanyl
and heroin and the overdose is like
we're all gonna die unless we get out of
here I mean we is it population control
what is it I just I don't understand but
I don't want this to be my legacy cuz
one day my kids get older right I don't
want them to come down here and look for
their mama
maybe [ __ ] cracked out like some of
the girls that I see no I don't want
that for myself
and I still try which is something that
I pride in myself you know that I have
never given up no matter how much [ __ ]
I've been through I can't even though it
may look like it on the outside there's
something on the inside of me that won't
give up and that's usually just human
nature because we're animals you know an
animal fight no it's just its nature but
drugs numb you to the point where you
just you you lose the fight
you know you just you lose the fight and
it makes me so sad to see people that
lose their drive [ __ ] I mean I'm an
alcoholic and that's one of that's like
the worst it really really is it's
everywhere um and if you don't use it it
makes you sick and you can die so even
though people can't look at it like oh
well you could just quit you know just
don't drink well [ __ ] you just don't by
the sack you know like how dare you talk
about my addiction but I you can
actually have a seizure and die you know
alcohol is the only thing that if you go
to jail right it's the only thing that
they give you detox medicine for anymore
they don't even give heroin addicts
detox medicine cuz even though their
body hurts and their body is addicted to
it too they can live without it
alcohol is the only thing that you
actually need medicine for and it's so
sad and I hate it every time I think a
drink I hate it it's almost like the
devil there are some times where I go to
where they sell shots in the morning cuz
I'm shaking and I have the DTS and I'm
actually I cry I weep when I'm taking
the first shot like [ __ ] here we go
again
but you need it so you know you gotta
take it and you're like damn how did my
life end up like this and you know we
have people who tell you you're so
beautiful you're so talented you're so
smart why are you here I've heard that
too
I don't know
I don't know I guess you know you don't
see it you don't see what other people
see in you and I had somebody tell me
the other day it actually broke my heart
they told me Queen you're letting this
place change you well duh I mean it's
inevitable that that's gonna happen but
they said you know the light that you
used to have when your eyes isn't there
anymore
and I think that that's part of the
dog-eat-dog so like there's two sides
there's either good or evil there's no
gray area it's either good or it's bad
and if there's no good around you
there's no good going on another choice
do you have
and then next thing you know you find
yourself becoming darker and darker and
meaner and meaner and they were right my
life doesn't shine the way that it used
to and I don't even get drunk anymore
damn it I can't I can't even enjoy my
drug which is [ __ ] up I'm only
drinking is to survive at least these
other [ __ ] get to not off you
know damn you do you talk to your kids
still no
what's up I haven't talked to them are
seen them if you could talk to them what
would you say yes damn Marjorie I love
them
and I miss them very much and I know
that mommy [ __ ] up right and if I
could change it all I would but just
know that I I never ever ever wanted
this to happen and please don't feel
like I abandoned you because that's not
what happened I never left you you were
taken there's a difference and they were
the best thing that ever happened know
you they saved my life even though it's
a [ __ ] that one because if it wasn't for
them I would have been dead yeah that's
what I would say
when you boil it down what do you think
the core of your problem is
God you know that would that would make
it to where I would blame everything on
my mom no I can't do that anger I would
say anger because it's a it's a it's a
[Music]
anger and hurt you know I mean because
there's stages to pain and once it turns
into anger and then there's rage and
there's no coming back from that I would
say being angry and not having anybody
to talk to you or anybody it's a relate
to you know because you know they give
you programs and [ __ ] try to put you
in counseling and [ __ ] but this
[ __ ] has a PhD and has never
been through anything you know they need
more advocates meeting more people who
have actually been through some [ __ ]
because if you've never actually been
through it you can't reach people the
way that somebody act that actually has
you know just like I believe because
like I said I'm a sinner I I believe
that if you haven't actually been
through what you're singing about you
shouldn't be singing that [ __ ] so how
are you gonna teach me about how to fix
my [ __ ] life if you would haven't
been through the [ __ ] to fix your life
right
yeah having the lack of
having a lack of resources probably an
anger diesel angry and not knowing how
to release it and so finding other ways
to release pain and range through sex
and drugs and music and alcohol and yeah
all the nuns should as long as I'm not
feeling it I don't care you know that's
one of my things out here as long as I
have music in my alcohol and some
cigarettes I'm okay and for a little
while that's true but then it gets cold
and you're alone
and then you realize look I might be
alone and that's one of the most painful
things because there's a lot of like
disturbing relationships out here I
don't want that I knew that all by
myself mark we need anybody to help me
do that but it's lonely yeah and
everybody thinks that oh man I know you
got it I know you got a gang of
[ __ ] on you you know you're so
pretty in
no of course they're all on me
but all I want is one thing and I don't
want that for me unless you're gonna
love me for all of my [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and all the things that I've
been through which is a big job you know
so if I ever do find that somebody right
they're gonna have to love me through
some [ __ ] and cheers to them but once
they get through all of that stuff I'm
an amazing woman
nobody blessed in this crazy that I
still believe in that you know even
being in through through what seeing all
this [ __ ] that I see I wish I could take
the camera right now and show you where
the [ __ ] I'm at but through being
through all this [ __ ] that I lived
through I still believe in love when I
see somebody and I'm walking down the
street and I see them in the gutter I
tell the [ __ ] up get up get your ass up
man like come on just you can't go out
like this not in the gutter dude put
your shoes on [ __ ] like you know I have
some pride in yourself
crazy huh and I still believe but I
still believe
you never know maybe all these things
that I'm going through is for somebody
else maybe that's the reason why you met
me today somebody out there needs to
hear that they can make it and please
don't make the same mistakes because you
might end up here and not everybody is
strong I consider myself very strong
not everybody is strong enough to live
through this Nikki thank you for coming
in thank you for having me
thank you for what you're doing Meeny
mori
we need more marks in the world [ __ ] my
alcohol is gone I'll give you money for
more